bear with me because this requires
explanation
paul krugman you may not know him but
he's the biggest joke on the new york
times comics page except
the times calls them op-eds in his
latest spoof he claims that biden will
be
quote the first modern president trying
to govern
in the face of an opposition that
refuses to accept
his legitimacy good one except first
biden is about as modern as a poodle
skirt and second the current president
has had to fight for four years against
an
opposition of elites often using a very
familiar word
krugman apparently doesn't recall any of
this right hillary
he knows he's an illegitimate president
he knows
he knows that there were a
bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
you were one of them she's not alone
though remember this clown
he was legally elected but the russian
uh uh
weighing in on the election the russian
attempt to have the election
and frankly the fbi is weighing in on
the election i think make the
make it makes his election illegitimate
that's too and i wonder how joe feels
about this
[Applause]
yes he does and who can forget those
boycotting the inauguration which was
meant to
underscore the illegitimacy and then
there's krugman's own words in a tweet
questioning trump's legitimacy and
that's one of many
so how does he forget all that was it a
head injury one cause from reading his
own columns
or maybe after using every single hoax
and racial smear against trump and his
supporters
he and the times just erased all memory
of it
maybe with help from these guys
we call it the neuralizer keep it simple
slit
thanks a lot thank you agent k uh ladies
and gentlemen if you will look right
here
that's my explanation perhaps in order
to maintain
a comical delusion so well documented
their only recourse is denial
it never happened krugman's lucky his
employer will indulge his madness
because it gets clicks
and their constant drum beat of
illegitimacy created a moral imperative
for trump's removal by any means
necessary
25th amendment impeachment election
fraud which is why america sees the
media
for what they are what's the word oh
yeah
illegitimate so dana
um is it a prerequisite for the media
just to forget everything you've ever
done
because if you did you would just be a
hypocrite every single day that way you
could keep just writing it
yeah just keep writing and keep writing
how did the how did his editors
not see this but then they did a secret
edit that's right
they went in and they tried to fix it a
little bit yes
because they were realizing that it was
just it's
preposterous to not even remember this i
mean that
the simplest of google searches would
have shown that but also pretty
audacious to write it anyway
um because if you remember president
trump was actually dealing with
calls for impeachment before his own
inauguration yes
and not and the other thing is the
resistance
obviously look i know that president
obama in his book
and he's talked about it before he
believes that he was
always um blocked the obstructionist
republicans they were
they were terrible and then after the
recount in 2000 i mean that was
pretty hard you had some people some you
know especially judges
saying that he wasn't legitimate uh
president either so
there's some precedence for this but in
this case
it is so well documented that everyone
said do not
help do not help the president do not
work with him do not join
don't even help him with the coveted
relief bill that americans really need
right now
the other thing i would mention is
there's this push to say that
republicans should just get behind joe
biden and not and
confirm all of his nominees let me give
you this example
president trump had 128 nominees of his
and the democrats asked for a cloture
vote basically that meant we're just
going to sit on this
we're going to delay it and delay it and
delay it that basically
all of them ended up with 90 votes or
more under obama only 12.
so think about that the scale of it 128
nominees held back
under obama it was 12. so when it is
said
that there was obstructionism in the
obama years i get it they think that
but the scale of it the data proves it
was much worse for trump
it's enough to make you want to swear
doesn't it dana um i am on my best
behavior
today thank you for having me back yes
so jesse yes what are your thoughts on
this blockbuster monologue
you know why i don't like fact-checking
democrats greg
why it leaves me less time for i told
you so's and what if that doesn't happen
and i and i wanted to uh add to your
well-researched monologue here in just
15 minutes i found other people that
called trump illegitimate
congresswoman barbara lee jimmy carter
stacey abrams tom arnold the new york
times washington post new york magazine
and salon
columnist now that was only in 15
minutes johnny my assistant wasn't here
i would have found a lot more
but i actually had to research it myself
the title of the column was intriguing
to me how
will biden deal with republican sabotage
right okay juan let's make a deal
you want to make a deal okay all the
things that democrats did to donald
trump you defended
you said we're perfectly legitimate so
therefore
all the things that republicans can do
to
biden equally defensible if they do the
same thing so
republicans can send swat teams on
pre-dawn raids into his associates homes
what they could impeach him in an
election year
they can a leak anonymous fake news
quotes about him
they could have prosecutors investigate
his charity
his family business they could boycott
his inauguration
they could do all of these horribly ugly
things that they did to donald trump
they could just do them to joe biden
and that would be perfectly fair under
this deal we're making do we have a deal
we have no difference but you defended
all the things they did against trump
why can't those things be done against
spiders let me get this straight so in
other words you have no
precursor in terms of russian
interference well here's the precursor
okay
it's china and we have that laptop from
hell i see
if you watched all of the hearings of
the fraud allegations today
you know those aren't baseless
allegations any more water
so there's more than enough to go on at
this point well i i tell you i hope that
dana's language
is in advance because i could use it at
the moment i'll tell you that because
that was a blank load right there but i
gotta say i mean i'm listening to this
conversation unless i'm thinking boy
what about isms that you mentioned jesse
because you know
waterbotism is a rhetorical trick that
you use when you don't want to talk
about the real issue on the table for
the day what's the
and i see three people saying oh you
know what about the democrats when they
said this
with regard to russia or whatever but
you don't want to address the real issue
and to me the real issue is that trump
keeps claiming
that this election is somehow
illegitimate and
fraudulent that something was wrong with
this election
but he has no evidence of it and today
today his attorney general bill barr
came out and said there's nothing wrong
with the we have no
evidence of any fraudulent misconduct
that would change the outcome
did you watch this election this is what
let me finish so this is what bill barr
the attorney general who is a total
trump
loyalist said today now trump is also
attacking georgia governor
kemp he's attacking georgia governor
ducey of arizona so georgia and
arizona just because they said we had
legitimate real elections and you lost
donald trump it's not a time there's no
issues he's attacking them
and you know what this is dangerous it's
dangerous to engage in this what about
ism because
people lose faith in democracy like the
democracy no
under trump because democracy under the
russians
but i'm just saying you have a problem
such a hypocrite
that's not a hypocrite did the russians
help
joe biden you undermine the presidency
no you don't want to ignore certain
things and engage with what about it
democrats don't want republicans or
conservatives to engage in what about
ism because it reminds them of all the
things that they've been doing
for four years now look in politics
there are two tracks here
there are these grassroots political
movements that oppose the current
occupant of the white house
we saw that under president obama with
the tea party we saw that immediately
when president trump took office with
the women's march
et cetera but the other problem that we
see which we did not see in previous
administrations is the
weaponization of government against a
political campaign and that is what this
resistance was all about it wasn't just
about
you know resistance on capitol hill
opposing president trump's agenda
it was about using the government
whether it was adam and
the other news with bill barr is that he
has now upgraded the durham
investigation to a special counsel
investigation because he thinks it's so
important
to look at the weaponization of
government that it should extend
into another administration and protect
him from being fired now
what about ism will someone like joe
biden or all these democrats
like adam schiff who demanded that
president trump protect
special counsel robert mueller afford
john durham the same when it comes to
this investigation that's to be seen but
the issues against trump were far more
serious in terms of not just
basic political opposition it was
embedded ingrained
opposition through different government
agencies and that
is a problem and people broke the law to
do it by the way there you go
all right we got to move on by the way i
defend what about ism is actually a
viable
debate for your sake you had to hide
from the real issue yeah
don't forget about analogies